foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing 10 things you missed in the
Deathly Hallows part one by the time the
Deathly Hallows rolled into theaters the
general public was already well versed
in the law of the Harry Potter world but
even the most knowledgeable potterheads
were liable to miss some of the smallest
details in the film with nuanced
decisions from filmmakers as well as
small callbacks to previous Potter books
there is plenty to unearth in the
Deathly Hallows part one and more than
enough things you might have missed
today we'll take a look at this
penultimate movie in the Harry Potter
series and cover all the little things
it might have passed you by 10. Equis
poster by the time the Deathly Hallows
went into production Daniel Radcliffe
had spent the better part of a decade
working within JK Rowling's Wizarding
World but unlike many of his Supporting
Cast Radcliffe never really had the time
to attempt any other type of production
while Alan Rickman and wraith fines had
stretched their legs in theater
television and dramatic films Daniel
Radcliffe was still mostly known for his
portrayal of the boy who lived but in
2007 the thespian took a brief departure
and joined the cast of the stage play
Equus although it was quite the
challenging performance Radcliffe proved
his worth and received worldwide Acclaim
for his acting and in the Deathly
Hallows part 1 if you squint your eyes
you can make out a nod to the play in
the diner scene 9. darker logo as you've
probably heard me mention before one of
the greatest ongoing Easter eggs in the
Harry Potter films is the continually
transforming Warner Brothers logo in the
earliest films the logo animation
appeared in bright blue and gold colors
but by the time of the Deathly Hallows
all the color had been sucked out like
it had received a dementor's kiss
8. Bill Weasley and Mad Eye Moody are
related madai Moody made his first
appearance in Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire unbeknownst to viewers
the skilled sorcerer was actually locked
up for most of the film in his place a
Death Eater by the name of Barty Crouch
Jr assumed to Moody's role as the new
defense against the dark arts teacher
for a while even Moody's closest
Associates at Hogwarts were fooled but
in the end Harry Potter and his friends
uncovered Crouch's secret now you might
not have known this but the actor who
portrayed madai Moody was actually
related to another cast member within
the Wizarding World if you take a second
to think about it you might actually
figure it out on your own but for those
of you that can't quite figure it out
I'll tell you Brendan Gleason the actor
who portrayed madai Moody is actually
the father of domino Gleason who we saw
take on the role of Bill Weasley in
Deathly Hallows part 1 one 7. no
hedwig's theme for most Potter films the
first few scenes are filled with a
familiar sound John Williams score and
Deathly Hallows part 1 is no different
but in this film's case there was one
small alteration to the playlist
typically when a Harry Potter movie
begins hedwig's theme or a variation of
it can be heard but the Deathly Hallows
part 1 is darker and more ominous in
tone hedwig's theme was omitted
foreshadowing the heartbreaking story to
come 6. Hermione's hair gets longer and
longer the Deathly Hallows brought a
massive change to the lives of Harry
Potter and his friends no longer were
they enrolled in school and navigating
their way through the complex world of
exams and social outings instead they
were traversing the British Countryside
on a mission to destroy the horcruxes
that Voldemort had hidden throughout the
nation
zintari Hermione and Ron were focused on
confronting the Don Claude they didn't
bother to keep up with smaller tasks and
you can see that with Hermione's hair
throughout the film her locks grow
longer and longer a sign of just how
many weeks the young Wizards had been on
the road 5. lucky number seven the
number seven is somewhat of a lucky
number in The Wizarding World if we
think back there were seven Potters the
night that Harry tried to escape from
the dursley's home that alone doesn't
seem so special but you have to remember
that seven appeared in a number of other
places it was the number assigned to
Harry when he assumed the role of
captain on the Quidditch team and
perhaps unluckily it was the number of
horcruxes that Voldemort created the
decision to have six Potter decoys
alongside the real Harry Potter
continued the use of seven in the series
and this wasn't a mistake the number
seven was actually a special magical
number in The Wizarding World Bridget
Wenlock a 13th century Witch and student
of numbers was the first to write a
theorem that proved Seven's magical
properties and it became the basis for
Wizarding arithmetic for centuries to
come I mean if wenlock's theorem was
able to convince even the most stubborn
dark wizard like Lord Voldemort then
there must have been more than enough
truth to her Claim about seven four
originally Harry Potter was going to be
animated before Warner Brothers ever
settled on creating a live-action
version of Harry Potter the studio
bandied about the idea of creating an
animated version JK Rowling would
famously fight against this proposal but
for the shortest moment there was a
chance that Dan and Radcliffe and all of
his castmates would have never appeared
on the Silver Screen perhaps partially
in an Ode to this concept the story of
the Pepperell Brothers wasn't shown in a
flashback like Dumbledore's first trip
to Voldemort's orphanage instead the
filmmakers decided to portray the
ancient tale through an animated C
sequence 3. Luna wasn't supposed to
dance one of the rare weddings during
Harry Potter's time in The Wizarding
World occurred during the Deathly
Hallows part 1. Ron's older brother Bill
tied the knot with his fiancee Fleur de
la core in an elaborate ceremony the
nuptials included a who's who of Harry's
allies and one of the most familiar
faces in the crowd was that of Luna
Lovegood at the wedding Luna can be seen
dancing around the floor but that wasn't
actually written into the script and it
wasn't actually instructed by director
David Yates instead that dance was
something that Luna's actress Ivana
Lynch came up with on the day of
shooting 2. worm tells death keeps
Marauder's Map curse alive the creators
of the Marauders map seem to have also
created a strange curse as a side effect
you see the creators wrote their names
on the map in a very specific order
Remus Lupine Peter Pettigrew Sirius
Black and James Potter of course they
didn't write their true names on the map
itself but that was the order in which
their nicknames were written in the real
world the death of these map creators
didn't seem to happen randomly or at
chance instead each of the map's
creators were killed in the opposite
order in which their names were written
James passed first during his Fateful
Encounter With Lord Voldemort on
Halloween night all those years ago and
Sirius Black met his demise during the
battle the ministry of magic when his
body was thrown through the veil of
death in the Deathly Hallows part 1
Peter Pettigrew died when Voldemort's
silver hand strangled him continuing the
map's curse and leaving Remus Lupine as
the last victim to fall 1. Vern Troy
left the Goblins of The Wizarding World
were one of the most iconic creatures
devised by JK Rowling far different than
the Goblins of other fictional worlds
Rollings were tiny cunning and
economically powerful we most often saw
the sentient creatures whenever Harry
Potter visited Diagon Alley and
traversed the complex path to Gringotts
Wizarding Bank there Potter marveled at
the hundreds of goblins working behind
the clerk's counter and the ones further
in who managed the complex rail system
of these Goblins the one most often
portrayed on the Silver Screen was a
devious Troublemaker named grip hook at
first this role was brought to Life by
American actor Vern Troyer but years
later when the goblin was set to
reappear and Deathly Hallows part 1 the
filmmakers decided to dip into their
British acting pool and use Warwick
Davis for this role as well and there
you have it 10 things you might have
missed in the Deathly Hallows part one
but even though we've covered a ton
today there's more to discover in the
film if you want to share anything
you've found be sure to leave it in the
comments below between the actor who
played crabs and fortunate stint in jail
to the Callback to Hermione's parents
relocation to Australia there's a lot to
uncover in the Deathly Hallows part 1.
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please be sure to like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
thank you
[Music]